- I'd love to go deeper.
Would you be willing to let
me analyze you a bit more?
- Oh, listen, if you're
willing to go in here.
- I'm ready.
- Listen, you don't wanna get in here.
I'm not afraid.
Let's step into my office.
Let's do it.
Okay.
You are obviously on the couch.
I mean, your legs are gonna
be really high in this seat.
(laughing)
It's a very high seat.
- Let's see.
- Is that how they are?
Yeah, I would fall asleep in therapy
if this is what it looked like.
- I actually.
- They'd be like open up
and I'd be like (snoring).
(laughing)
- You sure this is a trip
you wanna take, sister?
- Yes.
Yes, brother, let's do it.
Okay, so when was the last
time you really cried?
- I'm crying inside right now.
- Oh, so you're
uncomfortable around people,
okay, okay, okay.
What's the one thing in life
you're still trying to find?
- My hair.
(laughing)
I swear.
- Here, you can borrow mine.
- I went to bed one night.
- You can borrow mine.
- Thank you.
(laughing)
- I found this lovely little piece.
You look beautiful.
- Thank you.
- You look beautiful.
Anyone can have hair.
What is the one thing--
- I went to bed one
night and it was there.
And I woke up the next
morning and it was gone.
- Me too!
That's why I'm wearin' weave, brother!
(laughing)
It's gettin' thin.
- I swear I've been bald since I was 12.
(laughing)
- That's all right.
It's tough, I like it.
Tough doctor.
- I read one time that 78% of
men would amputate a body part
rather than be bald.
- I know one they wouldn't.
(laughing)